hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
today we're on idea number 23 out of 24.
there's only going to be one more after
this
and today's idea is criticality and
complexity once again we squeeze two
words together
a little bit different than our previous
ideas for one thing you may not even
have heard the word
criticality in this context some of you
of course will have
but also the idea of complex systems
which is basically going to be the theme
of today's video is a little bit
different than what we talked about
before for the following reason you know
in
a couple of the last videos we've been
working our way up
saying that we started uh or at least by
the middle of the series we were down
into the microscopic world
understanding quantum field theory and
atoms and all the way up to matter
but then when these little tiny pieces
come together to make bigger pieces
you can see various bits of collective
behavior which we talked about in the
emergence video
or you can make the whole universe which
we talked about in cosmology
but there's another possibility which is
that the different pieces come together
in a
complicated way and that's when we get
what we call a complex
system so it's a very natural thing to
talk about the reason why it's a little
bit different than the other topics
is because unlike everything else we've
talked about even though there's
research going on in every single idea
that we've talked about
they are what thomas kuhn would have
called paradigmatic
science so kuhn in his book the
structure of scientific revolutions
distinguished between paradigmatic
science where you have some paradigms
you have some
special favorite ways of thinking
problems to work on
examples to guide your thought and
therefore you know what questions to ask
and where to go next in a very real
sense complexity complex system studies
is
pre-paradigmatic okay you could argue
about that but
it's still a field very much in
development it's newer than the other
ideas that we were talking about
the idea of things being complicated is
very old but the idea of
complexity as a phenomenon worthy of
study
in its own right regardless of what the
specific implementation of it is
is still a little new so people are
still trying to figure out what are the
right questions to ask what are the
right examples to look at
uh so rather than sort of giving you the
central ideas
it's not clear where the central ideas
are here where it's going to be more
like we're wandering through the
foothills of a mountain range that we're
not going to get to glimpse entirely
there's an enormous amount of work
being done in complex systems and we're
just going to hint at it give you some
of the sort of tools that people use so
you're not surprised when you hear other
people talk about it
so one big question why is it why is it
not yet paradigmatic science well
we don't even know what we mean when we
say complexity okay we don't even have
the definition
and of course there's probably not a
definition things can be complex in
different ways
so we ask the question uh when you say
complex systems the complexity
of what is something you can ask and i
don't mean
uh of which system you're looking at i
mean
what kind of thing are you looking at so
for example
uh mindscape podcast listeners uh
might have heard me talk with scott
aronson recently
scott is a computational a theoretical
computer scientist who works in
computational
complexity theory so there what they're
doing is they're looking at the
complexity of
problems or questions okay that's one
thing that could be complex
problem problems or questions so it
turns out that
you know multiplying two numbers
together is much simpler
than taking a big number and factoring
it into its prime factors
so given a question how many steps does
it take to answer that question is a
measure of complexity
of a problem there's another set of
measures of complexity for
processes or algorithms
so this is rather than being given a
question and you're asking it
you're saying well i i have some input
and some things happen to it and then
there's some output and so
is the thing that you're doing complex
or is it simple is that
process over time complex or simple
that's a question
you can ask so we're going to talk about
uh we're not talking about either one of
those things
today we're going to talk about the
complexity of things
broadly construed okay objects
organisms the internet biological
networks right the biosphere
all sorts of networks and complex things
made out of little things
big and small okay we want to say what
is
what is the definition of a system a
thing being complex and then what are
the properties that it has and then how
does it get that way right those are the
kinds of things you want to ask
so even then even when we say okay we're
just talking about
the complexity of objects of things
right um
and we're counting things like the
internet or the biosphere as an object
in this
we still don't have a definition of
complexity that everyone agrees on again
i keep saying that what i mean is
there's more than one sense of the word
complexity that is interesting to talk
about
so let me uh just sort of highlight this
by talking about one of the most famous
measures which is the kolmogorov
complexity
and this also gives me a chance to
apologize to professor kolmogorov
whose name i misspelled and
mispronounced in the
come all probability up complexity uh
is a way of there's different ways of
thinking about it so we're going to be
very casual here
think of a string of numbers okay
and ask yourself is the string of
numbers
simple or complex and the way that this
kind of thing happens is
you sort of look at systems examples
and you say do i think it's simple or do
i think it's complex and then you sort
of sit back and think well why
did i think that what was the actual
reason that i would give for thinking
that
so let's consider the string uh five
five
five five five five and it goes on for
a million digits it's always the number
five that's pretty simple
right like it's just the same number
over and over and over again
uh and so you might say well okay that's
simple because it's just the same number
over and over again
but then what about the string one two
three four
five six seven dot dot and when you get
up to nine zero you go one two three and
just repeat forever okay
that's not the same number over and over
again but you say aha but it's still
simple it's not very complex because
it's just a repeating pattern
so maybe what i mean by simplicity if i
contrast simplicity with complexity
maybe what i mean is just that simple
things repeat themselves over and over
okay so kamalgrove comes along and says
well okay what about this
series 1 2 2 3
3 3 four four four four dot dot dot
so you just repeat the number the number
of times it is but then when you get to
zero
you repeat it ten times then you have
eleven ones and twelve twos just
increase the length of those strings
every time okay
well there's no repetition there right
that that series does not repeat itself
but
but still it's pretty simple right like
i just describe it in a couple words
and that's the key right i can describe
it in a couple words i give you a short
example and then you instantly in your
mind
know how to figure out the rest of it
right so kolmogorov's insight was to say
okay maybe the
i can i can talk about the simplicity or
complexity of a string of numbers by
asking
how hard is it to describe what the
string of numbers is
so if i have just sort of a you know a
random string seven six
zero six three one zero
nine eight dot dot okay what if there's
no structure there
right there's no way to tell you what
that thing is you have no idea what the
next number is going to be
so you say to yourself okay these look
to me to be simple
and this one maybe is complex
now a series of truly random numbers you
can see already
i want to argue you know is is this
complex or not
uh it's random there's not it's not like
useful kinds of complexity right it's
just hard to describe
without just giving you the whole number
so you instantly see well there are
different notions of the word complexity
the
kolmogorov complexity captures the
notion of
how hard is it to describe that's a
version of complexity
so the kamalgrove complexity is
literally the length
of oops of the shortest algorithm
and you need to like fix a programming
language or something like that
that outputs the number
the number okay so given a number you
say to yourself well look the number
five i can write a very short computer
program that just repeats the
the number five over and over again even
if it's a million digits long
i just do it a loop and i don't know
what your favorite programming language
is but do a loop
a million times it prints out the number
five um
likewise for these repeating sequences
or for these sequences that have some
pattern built into them
but for a sequence that is just random
numbers
the shortest program that would print it
out just says print
and then the number and so if the number
is a million digits long
or a billion or a trillion digits long
okay that program will be
much longer than the little tiny pattern
program
so comol raw complexity captures the
idea that there is a pattern hidden
within the number that you can reduce to
a tiny little algorithm
once you get to big numbers most numbers
will have the feature that the shortest
algorithm will print them out is roughly
speaking
print and then the number okay most
numbers are complex in that sense
but not all of them like consider this
number three
one four one five nine you know so on
two six five dot well you know what that
number is it's pi
it's the digits of pi in decimal
expansion so if you know a little bit
about pi you know there are
series uh that you can write down
infinite series that will approximate pi
to any number of digits
and it's very easy in a small number of
lines of computer code
to write a program that will output the
digits of pi okay
so even though there's no structure in
here in the sense of a simple repeating
pattern or a simple rule that gives you
these numbers
the kamalgirl complexity of pi is very
very small
because there is a simple algorithm that
outputs it
and that reminds you that it's hard to
tell when you look at a number whether
it's kamalgrove complexity is big or
small so here's another number that i
have written down here uh 8 2
1 4 8 0 8
six five one dot dot and you look at
that
and you say well no there's a bunch of
eights there but that's not
statistically unlikely really that
there's three of the same number
uh in that in that sequence i don't know
what that number is it looks random to
me
turns out these are the digits of pi
starting from the 100th digit
okay so it's actually very easy to write
down a short computer program that
prints this out even if i had a million
digits like this
so but you wouldn't know if i just gave
you that unless you're one of the people
who memorized all the digits of pi
right or if i did it for a slightly
different number if i did pi
plus the square root of 2 the 100th
digit of that again
i could print that out in a very short
computer program but you would never
recognize it as complex
so come over complexity is very
interesting it captures
something interesting that there are
some systems
whether strings of numbers or whatever
that have simplicity underlying them
whereas others are just sort of you need
to specify everything that's going on
but that's not the only measure of
complexity in fact it's not going to be
the most useful one for us
here it is a useful measure but it's not
going to be the one that we're going to
care about here i just wanted to sort of
put it on the table there
to highlight some of the issues and
because many of you probably thought of
or or know about
the commonwealth growth complexity
already okay so for us we're going to
look at
systems in a very broad sense
uh when are they complex and when are
they not
and one feature in fact the feature that
we'll be talking about again you know
there's
once you get into the processes and how
things do things over time and
process information things become
infinitely more complicated let's just
look at objects at a moment in time
one of the things that makes them
complex has to do with
how they manifest themselves in terms of
spatial sizes
okay so a small like something that is
simple
if you have one big thing there you go a
circle
circular circle-esque right if that's
your whole thing that's pretty simple
i think right you just drawn a circle
it's a certain size
and it's not just because there's one
thing if you draw many circles but
they're all the same size
and they're in some pattern well then
even though my circle drawing is not
perfect that's also pretty simple right
there's nothing
you can once again in that out in the el
camogra sense you can sort of see how to
build that up
whereas if you have a bunch of circles
but of
very different sizes in different places
doing different things
then you're tempted to say well okay
that to me
looks complex you know it's hard for
human beings
to uh actually generate random numbers
or random things so i think that i have
like three favorite circle sizes in my
diagram but you know what i mean
right here maybe i can make it look a
little bit more realistic
by drawing making two medium-sized ones
there um
a variety of different sizes that begins
to resemble what you and i would
intuitively think of as complex and
remember the game we play here is
we look at something you know we have
this idea already of complexity
informally and this is sort of what
pre-paradigmatic science does it says
like how can we
formalize that how can we capture the
essence of it in a way that we can make
rigorous and quantitative and then do
science to it so the definition
is not given to us that's not the
starting point the starting point is our
intuition we try to make it
formal and rigorous so here is an idea
um
structure at
multiple many scales
so something is going on at small scale
some intermediate scales
something going on at large scales this
seems to be
and this i'm not going to undo this this
is what i'm saying
one of the central ideas of complexity
is that there are things going on at
multiple scales it's not just the same
damn thing over and over again
at some particular scale okay and that's
interesting because you know you might
think well that's not surprising the
universe is full of things in many
different sizes
and scales and that's true but the
universe is complex that's not a
that's not a contradiction or you know
it's not evidence against it
the interesting thing is that many
systems that you might think of as
complex
nevertheless have a single
characteristic size
right so um atoms have a single
characteristic size the bohr radius
not all atoms are exactly the same size
there's absolutely a difference
but it's a small multiple times the bore
radius right
there's various things that you can do
you know neutron stars have a
characteristic size they're all
basically the same size if they were
bigger they
they were heavier they would collapse
into black holes they were lighter they
wouldn't make neutron stars in the first
place there's sort of a window they can
be in
but even more than that even things that
you really think of as complex like an
atom or a neutron star you might think
of as simple
but think of like biological organisms
okay so the example i looked up on
wikipedia
was the mass of an adult
male african bush elephant
african bush elephant and
you know there's different kinds of
african elements elephants and the men
and women are very different
but here are the the male african bush
elephants
you can look up you know what the mass
is and the mass of a typical
african bush element is about 5 900
kilograms
there you go you can look it up on the
internet um
i could be wrong about this number but
that's what i remember looking up um
so what does that mean when you read
that in wikipedia does it mean that
every single adult male african bush
elephant is
exactly 5900 kilograms no you know
that's not true
it's a typical thing it's sort of an
average but it's not just an
average uh saying that the typical
mass is this knowing what you know about
elephants
if you found an adult male african bush
elephant that was
one kilogram or that was 500 million
kilograms
you'd be really really surprised so it's
not just
that there is an average size that is
that most things are
pretty close to the average size
relatively speaking right
you don't find elephants that are this
big that's just not something that you
find
very often anyway so if you were to plot
and this is what we do this is your the
complex systems research is sneaking up
on you here
if you plot you know x which is the mass
of an elephant
versus the number of elephants of mass
x i'm using x because we'll use it later
for other things
uh it looks kind of like this right
there is a peak at some value and it's
distributed in a sort of bell curve like
shape and you'll forgive me for the my
inability to draw perfect
gaussian bell curves but that's
basically roughly what you mean there's
a
central value x0 here
5900 kilograms and there's some
dispersion or standard deviation around
there
but that's basically what you see and so
that's why if that's the distribution
you'd be very very surprised to see an
adult
male african bush elephant which is one
kilogram or 500 million kilograms
those are very small numbers here on the
plot in fact they're zero for all
intents and purposes given the finite
number of elephants
in the world okay so this kind of bell
curve
is extremely frequent extremely common
in nature
it's not everywhere you know just
because things have distributions does
not mean they're bell curves and that
that's
important and there's other curves other
than this one that kind of look bell
curve-ish and there's all sorts of
details but we're going to ignore most
of those details for the moment
there are a set of things in the world
that look
distrib as if they're distributed
according to this kind of distribution
so this kind of bell curve distribution
is called a gaussian if you're a
physicist
uh if you're a statistician or a
mathematician this kind of distribution
is so common that they just call it the
normal
distribution i think that's why they
call it the normal distribution there's
all sorts of other
reasons why that might be the word but
it's called the normal distribution
and it looks like in math terms that the
number of x forgetting about the
normalization because you can just
normalize it by
making it a frequency or making a
probability density you can divide by
the total number of elephants okay
uh then it is equal let's just say
proportional to
e to the minus x minus
x naught squared over two
sigma where x naught is the mean
there we've drawn it right up there and
sigma is the standard deviation
it's the width of the bell curve
and it's this number right here so if
sigma is big
then let me make sure that if you're not
familiar with my handwriting you know
this is a sigma oops
come on sigma
still not a very good sigma sorry about
this it's been a long day already
um so if sigma is big then it's very
spread out and then the peak will go
down if we normalize it in some way but
basically you just need these two
numbers to tell me what kind of gaussian
or normal distribution you have where is
it centered and how
fat is it or how thin is it how narrow
it is and
like i said this appears over and over
again uh
in nature there's various quantities
that obey this particular kind of
relationship
um it doesn't have to be elephants right
the height of so you need to be careful
right
if i say the height of let's say adult
american human beings
uh well then it might be a little bit
bi-modal because there's women
and there are men and there are slightly
different heights if you don't say adult
then you have a tail
because there are children in the world
right who tend to be shorter et cetera
so you have to be careful but
nevertheless there are many examples
where there is some sort of bell curve
distribution
and why why is it that distribution so
number one
why is it sort of localized at some one
particular
mean value with a small relatively small
deviation around it
and number two why is that shape at all
and you might say well okay maybe the
shape is the bell curve
just because it's simple right so it is
simple
but a step distribution
is equally simple and we're using the
word simple here without defining it
what i mean here
by simple is that it only takes these
two numbers to define it right the mean
and the standard deviation then i know
exactly what kind of bell curve i have
so let me consider a step distribution
i'm not going to go into great detail
here but what if n of x was just
0 and then for some set of values it was
flat
and then it was zero after that right
then once again i could call the middle
x naught and i could call the width here
sigma and those two numbers would
completely
specify my distribution if i if i
normalize it when i say normalize it
what i mean is
the area under the curve is fixed to be
one or some some other number but some
known number
so otherwise i don't i would have to
tell you the height of the distribution
as well but that's also true both for
the bell curve and for the step function
so for the step distribution for this
flat thing
it's just as simple and yet we don't
find many distributions in nature that
actually look like that
right it's relatively rare why is that
and so there's a reason as it turns out
i wouldn't be asking this if there
weren't a reason
there's a reason called well let's say
there are
reasons and one of the reasons is called
the central limit theorem
and this is not exactly uh crucial to
complexity science but it's officially
cool that i should tell it to you anyway
many of you know the central limit
theorem already so i'm
not going to either prove it or even
state it in generality but i'm going to
give you the essence of it
so the central limit theorem says you
know imagine you start with
some
some random variable some random number
that has
and just for simplicity let's say it has
a distribution
and of x that is a step function and it
is also
it's not a step function a step
distribution that is centered around
zero let's make my life easy okay by
centering it around zero
and what i want to do is take many
samples so
take let's say n equals a hundred
samples from that distribution which
means that i will randomly choose a
number
with the probability given by this
particular function you
saw the probability video you know what
that means okay
and then add them together
so add up my hundred random numbers
sampled from this distribution
okay and then divide just to make my
life easy this is an optional step but
divide by
the square root of n which equals 10 in
this case
okay and then say okay i get a number
right and so i'm gonna do that process
get a hundred numbers add them together
divide by ten
get another hundred numbers and we do it
again and again another hundred numbers
add them together divided by ten another
hundred numbers
and so i will generate a different
distribution which is not
the distribution i start with but the
distribution
of these processes that all include
getting a hundred random numbers
okay so get a different distribution
what does that look like
well the the new distribution will
always be
a normal distribution and why is that
even though i start with a step
distribution the point is i didn't need
to start with a step distribution
almost any there's some of course
mathematical restrictions but
if i if i had something that was like
you know this
did the same thing i would still get a
normal distribution at the end of the
day
um so yeah here's a normal distribution
let me plot it there we go
slightly better looking bell curve than
i had last time why is that
well look if i'm picking random numbers
from this distribution right there's one
there's one there's one there's one
the vertical there's no height
difference there
the the height doesn't make any
difference is what i mean and i add them
all together
there'll be some positive numbers some
negative numbers typically
you'll get a number close to zero right
you know there'll be cancellations
between the pluses and the minuses and
so you're going to get
a large number of answers that are close
to zero relatively speaking
but sometimes rarely all of your
random numbers that you choose will just
happen to have sort of
bunched up over here near the negative
side
okay and then you will get just by
chance a number
over here right out on the tail far away
from the central point
it's rare but it's possible so this
and that's the central limit theorem the
central limit theorem says start with a
random variable with almost any
distribution
uh construct a new distribution by
adding up many examples and then
normalizing
and you will converge to a normal
gaussian
bell curve shaped distribution so the
idea is
maybe something like this is behind why
this is true for elephants right in
other words
maybe the height of an elephant is is
set by
the action of a whole bunch of random
things just being added together
right uh genetic features dietary
features
accidents the elephant got into when it
was young and so forth
uh evo devo sort of genetic kind of uh
issues in biology
who knows what the random factors are
but the point is it's very easy to
imagine
mechanisms that will naturally give you
a normal distribution and this is part
of the game that we're going to start
playing here in complex systems
we're going to study the features of a
system
in terms of like the number of times you
get this the number of times you get
that
and then we're going to ask okay given
that distribution that we get what is
the mechanism that could lead to that
and for gaussians for normal
distributions it's it's hard to do that
because the mechanism is so generic
right like almost any additive complex
process like that with random numbers
thrown in
is going to give you a normal
distribution that's the beauty and power
of the central limit theorem and one
thing that we notice is that
there is a typical scale remember we
said that complex systems have structure
at many scales
the size of elephants doesn't have
structured money scales most elements
are
around 5 900 kilograms okay so
if that's true and it's so robust and
it's so easy to get how in the world do
we get structure at all scales how in
the world do we get complex systems
in nature so this is where the word
criticality comes in i've gone i don't
know 20
30 minutes already without even telling
what criticality is um
criticality actually is a word that i
think
originated in the study of phase
transitions um
but for our purposes today and i'll tell
you why that is true but for our
purposes today
it is it corresponds to power law
distributions
so the idea of criticality is
more narrow criticality implies power
law distributions usually but power law
distributions do not
uh imply criticality so i'll explain
exactly what i mean by criticality
in a second but first i will tell you
that even without telling you what it is
it leads to something called parallel
distributions what does that mean
that means that the number of things
has a function of i shouldn't write it
that way should i
the number of things as a function of
their size so n sub things
whatever those things may be elephants
or whatever as a function of their size
is going to be equal to some constant so
proportional in other words
times the size to some power
that's what power law means and
typically as the size gets bigger things
get more rare
so we'll make it minus some power alpha
okay and that's a power law and
so size is the independent variable we
say like four different sizes what are
the number of things that we're going to
get
so you raise it to the power minus alpha
and you might ask what is alpha well for
different
things for different things that we
might look at alpha will be a different
number okay so
one thing that if you're playing this
game if you you ask number one
are my things that i care about
distributed according to a power law
and if so what is the slope of the power
law
so this is called the slope now why in
the world is it called the slope it's
not the slope
this is you know i know what math looks
like if i actually plot
something like this you know like if i
have n is proportional to
x to the minus one for example and here
is x
then it goes like this that's it's a
curve it's not slope at all
uh so the point is i take a logarithm of
both sides so i'm going to make a log
log plot
i probably have already done this before
in the biggest ideas videos
and so when i take the log of n
well that's the log of k
times s to the minus alpha if s is the
right so s is the size here right
and there's a rule of logarithms that
maybe you don't know but i'm telling it
to you
two rules one is the logarithm of a
product
is the sum of the logarithms that's one
of the nice things about it
the other is the log of something to a
power
is that power times the log of the
something
so this means that log n equals
log k minus alpha
log s okay so this
curve representing a power law becomes
on a log log plot here's log n it's just
proportional
to log s and minus alpha is the slope
there you go that's why it's called the
slope so if you plot
log n versus log s and this we're going
to be making plots like this over and
over and over again
it will look like exactly a straight
line with slope minus alpha
okay so power laws
correspond to straight lines
on log log plots
that is a crucial feature so i'll just
we'll make log log plots over and over
and over again
okay good so what i wanted to say was
the word criticality implies you know
when you're at a critical point
then you have a power law distribution
of things going on
and here's the math behind what that
means what it implies is that
there is a straight line in a log log
distribution okay
now let me tell you why we call this
criticality uh
criticality comes from phase transitions
which is just the physics phenomenon of
you know going from one phase like water
going from liquid water to ice
or liquid water gas or vice versa in any
of the different directions right so
a material or a kind of stuff is in a
phase
if it has a certain relationship between
its different properties
like if you have liquid water or a gas
like oxygen at some temperature or
something like that there's a
relationship between the density the
pressure
the temperature things like that a
relationship called the equation of
state
and if you change phases then that
relationship
changes so the relationship in density
and pressure is different for ice than
it is for liquid water
okay and the phase transition i mean
it's sort of
tangibly obvious to you because ice is
solid and water is liquid
but that is actually a consequence of
the fact that it's in a different
phase so phase transitions as it turns
out
have this power law like behavior for
what well let me tell you what let me
look particularly at the classic example
which is the ising model and
i would like to use an example like you
know ice or something like that but
the icing model is something we
understand much better as physicists you
may or may not have ever heard of it
but for condensed matter physicists the
izing model is the ultimate spherical
cow right so for cosmologists the
universe is the spherical cow
for particle physicists the simple
harmonic oscillator or for quantum
mechanics the harmonic oscillator is the
spherical cow
for condensed matter physicists for
people who work with materials the
ising model is the ultimate spherical
count what the izing model is
is a set of coupled so interacting
magnetic spins
or little dipole magnets if you want so
you imagine some sort of lattice
uh of sights a little checkerboard
pattern here
and there are spins that are either up
or down okay
up up down down up down and
the point is that there is an energy
these spins are talking to each other
right and they want to be aligned
right it's lowest energy when all the
spins are lined up when they're pointing
the same direction it costs energy to
make them be
anti-aligned and there's not they're not
in between they're either up or down
that's the icing model okay
you're not allowing them to go up and
down or in between they're either up or
they're down
so what you can do is you can calculate
the energy for any given configuration
that's kind of what you do and there's
different games you can play so you can
put
if you really imagine that these are
magnetic spins so the reason why i said
magnetic is because real magnetic spins
do have that property they do want to
line up i can also
put the whole thing in a magnetic field
and then most of them want to line up in
along the magnetic field i could also
put the whole thing in a heat bath
so i have a bunch of particles a bunch
of atoms bumping into each other and
then they want to knock them out of
alignment right these sort of random
buffeting forces
will act on them so this very simple
system is actually kind of rich
in uh phenomenological possibilities you
can study it you can study
this is the two-dimensional ising model
right it's sort of a lattice on a plane
well i can write
interacting spins on a line the
one-dimensionalizing model i can make
them in three dimensions in filling
space or whatever i want
so the icing model is is actually you
can see why it's the spherical cow of
condensed matter physics
so at low energy
all the spins line up
so for don't put it in a background
magnetic field so forget about the
magnetic field
filling all of space here just let the
spins themselves interact
they will either want to be all up or
all down
okay so this is an example of what
spontaneous symmetry breaking right
remember when we did
gauge theories and we talked about
symmetries that could be spontaneously
broken
there's a symmetry of the underlying
theory that is broken by the vacuum
state of the theory
so in this theory if you just want the
spins to be coupled
so this is low energy
and this is high energy
so then either they would all be up or
all be down
so even though the theory doesn't care
about up versus down there's a symmetry
uh the vacuum state is either all up or
all down so there will be spontaneous
imagery breaking
in the vacuum okay and that's pretty
easy
so one way of thinking of that is to
define
a domain so a domain is
a spatial collection of spins that are
all pointing in the same direction so if
i'm looking correctly here
this looks like a domain of upward
pointing spins
so is this so is this okay so these are
domains
and so what we're saying here is that
all the spins want to line at low energy
so in other words there's one
big domain
this is not what i drew here in the
little picture
but what i'm saying in words is that the
lowest energy state is just one big
domain everything is either pointing up
or pointing down
this picture has you know if i i circled
the
upward spins here are the downward spins
here are the different domains and
they're sort of
different sizes of different domains
okay but
if you now so we're not going to put an
external magnetic field in but let's put
it at a different temperature
let's heat it up let's put it in the
oven okay and let it be
buffeted by photons and air molecules
and stuff like that okay so now you have
a high temperature
and if the temperature is very high what
does that mean just means high enough
like there is a temperature sufficiently
high that
sufficiently high that these
interactions here
between the spins are irrelevant like
okay it's a little bit
lower energy to be aligned than
anti-aligned
but if the temperature is so high that
they're just being buffeted back and
forth that's not going to matter
okay so at very high temperature there's
no correlation between the spins the
spins are just doing every single spin
is just completely random
so it's an entire entirely random
so what you expect is that at low energy
um
there's just one big domain at high
temperature
it's a low energy and zero temperature
at high temperature the domains are
going to be very very small
given that one single spin happens to be
up there's no reason
for any of the spins next to it to be
either up or down they're being buffeted
randomly okay so some of them will
randomly be up
but there's no reason to get a big
domain of all plus
up spins or or down spins for that
matter so
if you were to plot here is just the low
energy the vacuum state
if you plot oops let me move this over
here
this is the label for the plot
um if you were to plot the the size of
the domains
versus the number of them it would
basically be at low energy it's one big
domain
so it's like that okay all the domains
at low energy
let me move this over here um well i got
the p
uh have basically the same size and that
size is the size of
the whole system whatever the box is
okay you imagine there's a finite size
box that we're doing this in
whereas if we ask the same question at
high temperature
plot size of domain versus the number of
the domains well they're all very small
so you get something like this
okay and then it falls off so in both
cases
there is sort of a characteristic
favorite size in the
low energy case the size is the size of
the box uh
in the high temperature case the size is
zero or something very very close to
zero some small number close to zero
but now if that's true so this is low
energy at zero temperature in fact
let's say it that way because i think
it's sort of the contrast is better this
is zero temperature
there's no external buffeting and here's
high temperature there's a difference so
guess what
somewhere in between there's going to be
a phase transition there's going to be
some temperature
at which you cross over from the phase
in which
everything wants to be aligned to the
phase in which everything wants to be
random so there is a critical
temperature you see where the word
critical is coming in here
so the critical temperature is that
crossover point and you might think that
well maybe what happens is
this peak starts from you know i guess
from your point of view uh
everything is at the biggest um size
if it's very low temperature and then
you raise the temperature and the peak
just moves right and there's a middle
uh intermediate scale and there's a
bigger scale but that is not what
happens
what happens i can't draw this very well
um
but let's imagine this is our box and we
have spins inside and what we're going
to get are domains
so here are domains of upspins more up
spins
and then some of them will be very tiny
and some of them will be bigger and what
we'll get is sort of a chaotic
random fractal mess with
structure at all scales so you might
have expected that just the size
smoothly changes but there is always a
favorite size but that is
not true at the critical point
what we call the critical point the
temperature so this is t
equals tc there is some temperature for
the izing model
given the strength of this interaction
that makes the spins want to couple to
each other
there is some temperature at which you
get behavior like this this is the size
and this is the number of domains of
that size
okay uh so you get really small domains
you get bigger ones you get bigger ones
and you get a power law this turns out
to be a power law
i think this depends i can't tell you
what the power law is because
there are different quantities you can
physically measure
that give you information and the size
of the domain is actually not the
easiest thing to measure the easiest
thing to measure is the correlation
length um you get a the difference
between
one spin yeah you have two spins at some
distance what is the probability they'll
be aligned versus anti-aligned
at low temperature they're probably very
aligned at high temperature is
completely random
and there's some crossover point and
that crossover
that correlation length goes to infinity
um
as some power near the critical
temperature
so the point is that even though
remember where we started here we said
that there's the central limit theorem
it says there are certain kinds of
random processes that give you
bell curves that give you normal
distributions here's a different kind of
physical process
that gives you not a special scale
skill but power at all scales okay
interestingly in the uh um
ising model we can exactly solve the
model and the one dimensionalizing model
i think ising solved it it's kind of
easy and there in fact is no phase
transition there's no critical point
the two dimensional one is harder but it
was solved i think by onsagger
uh and actually the four-dimensional one
has been solved by quantum field theory
methods and then
uh no one has solved the
three-dimensional one exactly yet so
if you want homework problem solve the
three dimensionalizing model exactly
that's that's a good homework problem to
think about
and we can go even further into this you
know there's
this um there's a relationship here
i'm just going to mention it without
giving you any insight whatsoever
because i want you to know the buzzwords
also
there's a relationship between this and
the renormalization group
remember we talked about renormalization
and uh
we had a little video on renormalization
and we said that well you know if you
have a lagrangian or hamiltonian let's
say
that looks like well there's a phi dot
squared term
and there is a derivative of phi over
space a gradient term
and there's a mass term squared and
maybe there's an interaction term lambda
phi to the fourth
and we did dimensional analysis right
and we said that well
m squared phi squared that m gets big
just by dimensional analysis
whereas these three terms have
dimensionless coefficients
so if you look only at energy scales
remember the normalization group let you
come up with an effective field theory
that was only valid
at energies below a certain cutoff so if
your cutoff is much smaller
than this mass scale here then there are
no excitations in your theory
that are energetic enough to make a
whole particle with that mass
so everything becomes essentially
massless and it's
that's the critical point there's a
there's a behavior where very very low
energies
things behave like what we call
conformal field theories that have no
scale
built into them that are something is
going on at every single scale because
this mass parameter
term becomes not important to what is
going on
in the physics of it so critical
behavior is very closely related
conformal field theories you'll remember
the phrase conformal field theories when
we talked about the ads cfd
correspondence in the
emergence video so conformal field
theories are a favorite playground for
quantum field theorists they're
field theories without any scales in
them something happening at all scales
so that's what i want you to have in the
back of your mind when you hear the word
criticality critical behavior means
something happening at every
scale and it is closely related for
obvious reasons to complexity
why are they not exactly the same thing
well you know critical behavior is well
defined we know exactly what that is
so there's a set of contexts in which
critical behavior happens phase
transitions and things like that
conformal field theories and we know
exactly what it is and what it does
is it relevant to all sorts of very
broad uh
complex systems you know maybe maybe not
depends on the system
probably but there are you know in a you
could have a 24
video series just on critical phenomena
and you would go into the fact that one
of the nice things about
this kind of behavior is that it does
appear to be universal you know i talked
about the ising model
but there are plenty of other systems
for which we have studied the phase
transitions and we find this critical
behavior we find power law behavior
in the correlations or the size of
domains or whatever you want to talk
about
so the idea that at a critical threshold
at a critical temperature at the phase
transition point you get
scale-free behavior there's correlations
on long scales and also on short scales
that doesn't seem to depend on the
details of the microscopic
physics again reminiscent of the
renormalization group
strategy so there's a whole bunch of
things you could talk about there but
we're trying to talk about big
macroscopic complex systems
so let's get there so that's why
power law behavior is also often um
related to what we call criticality uh
but let's just talk about the idea of
power law behavior more generally
so power laws what's so great about them
well one great thing is that they are
scale free
so not only is there no special scale
but there's no scale at all
okay this is this is a just a
mathematical fact about a power law here
there's no peak in this power law
distribution if you look at it but more
carefully mathematically
so if we plot we should have been
careful here
sorry i'm trying to be careful so this
is the log of this and this is the log
of size i'm always going to make log log
plots so
just so you know when you go out into
the real world um
in this game every plot is a log log
plot to a very good approximation so
people stop telling you
that they're doing a log log plot versus
a linear plot and therefore
you can get confused so i'm going to try
to keep telling you but i
sometimes i suppress it also so this is
log of you know some number
of things going on and this is log of
some quantity that they depend on
uh the size right s and
let's say that we have a power law so
their power law
is n of s is k times s to the minus
alpha
okay uh so the immediate thing we see
is there is no s zero you know when we
said when we had a
gaussian distribution there was a mean
right there was a place you go in the
middle
and that was x zero x naught this there
is no s naught in this formula this is
just a
you know there's a power law
distribution there's no mean for it
um there's no special place to be no
special size no favored size and also
mathematically
there's no mean you could actually you
know there's no uh central point
to this distribution one way of seeing
this
is that if we let if we change variables
so let's let s be
let's substitute in some number lambda
just some fixed parameter lambda
times a new variable s bar so s is the
variable
like the size of the elephant or
whatever or the size of the domain in
the icing model
s bar is just the same variable in
different units
right so we've changed from kilograms to
pounds or something like that okay
well then what happens to n of s n of s
bar is now k times
lambda s bar to the minus alpha
but that's just k times lambda to the
minus
alpha times s bar to the minus alpha
and i can just define that to be k bar
s bar to the minus alpha where k bar
i just made up and it is k times lambda
to the minus alpha
so the point is i start with this form
in these units or this variable and i
end up with this form
but they're the same forms even though i
change the size of my units
that's what it means to be scale free it
doesn't matter what scale
we use what size we use doesn't matter
we look if we're using kilometers or
megaparsecs or whatever
we'll still have this exact functional
form for the behavior
of the of the distribution with the same
exponent
still to the minus alpha power that
didn't change okay
and there's another feature about these
power laws
uh namely there are black swans
nicholas tuldab has made this uh very
famous uh what that means is so here is
number log number and remember you know
i'm plotting these but the logarithm
of a number less than one is a negative
number
right so this plot actually goes
negative
if you want it doesn't stop and this is
log of whatever we're looking at
s so if this is our power law behavior
that we know about what would on this
log log plot
what would a normal distribution look
like what would the gaussian
distribution look like
it doesn't look like a bell curve it
looks like a velcro of an ordinary
linear plot on the log log plot it looks
kind of like an upside down parabola
so this is the normal
and this is the power law
and we see they're obviously very
different the normal distribution has a
favorite size
and here
this is what's called the heavy tail
so what that means is the probability
of getting a very large thing whether
it's a domain in the izing model or
whatever
we'll give you other examples in just a
second but the
probability of getting something at
large s
is enormously higher for a power law
distribution than it is for normal
distribution and that's because because
all these are logarithms
a small deviation in this direction
leads to a huge difference
in size you exponentiate the difference
and given this upside down parabola sort
of shape
the deviation for large s is really
really really big
so it's called a heavy tail because if
your probability distribution is power
law
rather than normal it is much more
likely given what you're used to
to be surprised by a ginormously large
event
okay so if you train your probability
intuition
on gaussians and power laws which is a
very sensible thing to do because they
appear all over the place
you can be very very surprised by
power law distributions so there are
claims that things like
earthquakes and solar flares and stock
market crashes
obey power law distributions i'm not
going to promise you that's true
but there's evidence for it and then
people debate it and what that means is
if you say you know oh well you know we
get an earthquake
let's take a solar flare it's my
favorite example because it might even
be true
we get a solar flare that is powerful
enough
sorry let's we get medium-sized solar
players every so often right and you say
well okay
i measure how often we get medium-sized
solar flares enough to sort of
disrupt some satellite communications
but it's sort of medium sized
and given how frequently we get them i
don't know every year every 10 years or
whatever
the probability of getting a ginormous
solar flare that would just wipe out all
electronics on earth
that seems to be very small because the
medium-sized ones are
semi-frequent but then by gaussian
statistics you'd expect the huge ones to
be very rare
but if the solar flares obey power law
statistics these black swans these these
very very apparently unusual events are
actually
much much more likely than you can than
you might think
and the reason why this is a difficult
controversial thing is
you know typically you don't know ahead
of time
what the distribution is like you know
god didn't tell you
it's not written in some sacred text you
have to actually do science to figure it
out
and what that means is you have data
okay and then you try to figure out from
the data what the underlying theory is
so let's say your data is this
there's your data and you go oh my
goodness i have a power law look at that
it's clearly not a normal distribution
anyway
well sure you have a power law but
are you going to say then therefore i
predict that very large s
it's still a power law do i predict that
it
stays on the curve way out there i mean
there are other distributions that might
go down like that
right so extrapolating beyond what you
already know
things you don't know becomes very very
difficult in this game
so all these are just cautionary words
that are very important if you're you
know
playing the stock market or deciding
whether or not to spend money hardening
our electrical grid okay these are real
world
problems for complex systems that's why
complex system research is kind of
important all right now having said all
that let's give you some more examples
so parallel distributions
are very common
they're not when i say i'm going to
write everywhere what i mean is not that
literally everything is a parallel
distribution but there are many many
things you can find all over the place
that are power law distributions i think
the first
famous one is the pareto distribution
uh what's his name vilifredo pareto was
an italian economist
okay so this actually um i think this is
the first one but you know the history
of this is a mess
so by all means look it up and tell me
that i'm wrong and i'll fix it um
in the q a video so pareto was an
economist and he studied the
distribution of
wealth he said you know how many people
have a certain amount of wealth versus
other amounts of wealth
now you can imagine a world where i
don't know the average wealth let's
imagine a happy world where the average
wealth was
uh half a million dollars the average
american was worth a half a million
dollars that's not the world we live in
sadly
um and furthermore imagine that what
that meant
is if the average american had half a
million
almost everyone was worth between two
hundred and fifty
thousand and seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars right
that is not the world we live in even if
there is an average wealth for americans
um there's a lot more people with below
that amount than there are is above that
amount because the distribution of
wealth
so here is uh you know the wealth w
and here's the log sorry log of the
wealth
log of the number of people who have
that amount of wealth and it's a power
law
i think it's approximately uh so this
alpha is like
1.1 in what pareto did something like
that uh
something like minus one and what that
means is
there are a lot of poor people and a
small number of people that have an
enormous amount of wealth and in fact
the way that pareto put this
was that 80 percent this is his 80 20
law 80 percent of people
sorry 80 of wealth
is owned ah
by 20 of the people
now we're not being normative here we're
not judging whether it's a good thing or
a bad thing
uh this is a power law that's that's
just an empirical fact about the world
what are you gonna do about it yeah that
you know that's up to you
also by the way the actual value of
alpha matters um if it were a much
stronger slope then there'd be much
fewer very very wealthy people so one
way of measuring inequality
is to say even if it is a power law what
is the slope of that power law and again
maybe it's good maybe it's bad okay that
we're not going to talk about and this
is circa 1900
when he said this so that's a power law
um
another famous one is zip's law
zip's law is about the frequency of
words appearing in
sentences in a language okay or senses
or books or whatever
so here is of course
if you have different words it's not um
uh there's not a number attached to the
word so we're gonna that we're gonna
attach a number to the word by just
ranking them
saying like there's the most common word
second most common word third most
common word
and give them number one two three et
cetera so here is the rank
and here's the frequency of that word
appearing
in books in the english language and
it's once again uh alpha is something
like
one in this case the number of the
frequency of the most popular words
compared to the least popular words goes
as the
rank to the minus one power what that
means is
the most common words appear very very
frequently
the least common words appear
infrequently so
if this is the word the it appears
a lot if this is the word criticality
it appears very very infrequently put in
quotes use mentioned distinction is
being
kept up here okay so in fact run the
numbers
about 135 words
represent about
50 of the english language
so if you take typical word books off
your shelves
right randomly selected uh rank order
all the appearances of the words then
you get this sort of very small number
of words or doing all the heavy lifting
heavy tail distribution right power law
um
there's a lot of interesting things to
say about this just in the in the
language game for one thing
it's true in english but it's it also
seems to be true in esperanto
which is a totally made-up language okay
so it's not just that english is weird i
mean
other languages have the same behavior
um even when you
artificially make it up the same
behavior sort of naturally happens
and one thing that is you probably are
thinking of if you carefully watched the
entropy video
is that this is a very low entropy
distribution in claude shannon's
sense of information theory right
shannon said
he was interested in sending signals
using words or symbols or something like
that over a wire
and he said what you want to be most
efficient is an equal probability for
all the different words
because then you learn something every
time you get a different word whereas
in the real english language there's
words that are sort of very common and
appear over and over again
that's why you can have predictive text
algorithms
and it's true that predictive text
doesn't always think that the is going
to be the next word it uses the word you
just typed but it's still the same kind
of thing there are
words that are much much more likely
than others to appear so the structure
that exists in things like a language is
another example of a power law
structure at all scales something
complex going on
there are more examples population of
cities is an
obvious one
cities website links
so this this turned out so i'm going to
say this one in particular because
it uh let me say what it is given the
web
the internet right you can ask well
given a certain web page a certain url
this is especially true back in the days
you know before
all the urls start becoming dynamical
and and keep cookies and things like
that but back in the day we had urls and
we knew where you went
we knew what the url was for every page
you were on and um
you could count you could say well how
many links
are there into that website and there
were a bunch of links to yahoo this is
before
google was even on the on the scene
right there a bunch of links to yahoo
ask jeeves and places like that um
amazon was pretty early right
and there were other there are many many
web pages where no one linked to them or
one other page linked to them there's a
small number
where there are many many links to them
so it's clearly
complex structure approximately power
law behavior
and this was noticed at roughly the same
time when people started to really
become
interested in these problems at a
quantitative level so understanding the
frequency of different links
the number of different links to
different websites is a classic problem
in this sort
of power law complexity game that people
play
okay so now so if this is true like we
gave you a reason why
gaussians or normal distributions are
common the central limit theorem
why are these power law distributions
also common but in different contexts
why what is going on so it's clearly not
the same mechanism that goes into the
central limit theorem
well uh that's complicated this is hard
and now we're going to get it's fighting
words and different choices of examples
to use people like different examples
people like to emphasize different
aspects of this but again i'm trying to
give you a flavor
of what's going on here so it seems
and the reason why it's a hard question
is because when we went back up here
to um the ising model
you know this idea of a critical
temperature
at low temperature everything is one
domain at high temperature it's random
if there's some fixed temperature in
between where you're exactly critical
that seems very like delicate right it
seems finely tuned it seems like
you have to work to get to that critical
point and stay there you can like pass
over it ice will melt that's okay
but being at the critical point seems
like it requires effort and
nevertheless this critical behavior of
power
law type behavior seems to be all over
the place that's
evocative it's it's it demands an
explanation why are there all these
power laws all over the place in
nature i mean so population of cities
obeys a power law
okay so there are many many small cities
very few huge
cities the world would be a very
different place
if every city had roughly 100 000 people
right like if some cities had 80 000
some had 120 000 but there were no
2 million or 20 million person cities
and there were no 1 000 person cities
right that'd be a very different world
what's going on that makes our world
have this complex structure in it
and the answer is part of the answer is
that in the central limit theorem
when we took many many random numbers
and added them together and made a new
distribution
that choice of many many random numbers
was independent like
what one random number was didn't affect
the next one
right so the very simple thing and
obviously true thing to say
is that in these real world examples
where people have money or cities have
population or words appear over and over
again
they are not independent of each other
they they're related to
each other so if you think about
populations of cities if you ask
yourself you know where do i want to
move
big cities you know there are people who
like big cities there are people who
like small towns but there are fewer
small there are fewer big cities and so
if you are a person who likes big cities
you're going to go to one of those even
though there are fewer of them so
the rich get richer and that's why
pareto is unsurprisingly
the first sort of example of a power law
rich people get richer because you can
use your money to make money
so this is called preferential
attachment
oops
the idea being that
[Music]
whether or not you grow over time
depends on how
big you are already i like i always
think of the example there's an eddie
murphy movie
coming to america where uh he's he's an
african prince
and you know they're talking about where
to go they're gonna go to america and
they're like there's so many choices
america is so huge we could go to either
new york or los angeles
you know there's there's there's certain
attachments that people have to
different places
and so preferential attachment is one of
the mechanisms
that is put forward to potentially
explain power laws remember
given any power law given any
distribution of anything if you if you
read the literature on this stuff number
one people will be arguing over whether
there's really a power law or not
and number two you're going to be
arguing over what is the mechanism to
explain that is universal so don't take
any of these suggestions as
set in stone um so here's a model
that we'll look at uh the model let's
say there are cities
uh and cities n there's not n cities but
there's
city n equals one and equals two
different labels on the cities
with population x
sub n just because we like using x as
our variable and p
is going to be used for something else
so we say that with
probability p
this is our model you a new person
randomly chooses a city to move to
so we give the small cities a fighting
chance like there's some chance that you
move to any city whatsoever
even you could move to the big ones in
this case also but
it's not dependent on this existing size
of the city so you treat the cities
equally
but then with probability 1 minus p
you move
to cities
uh with probability
weighted
by x n so let's say you move to city n
in other words um there's some
probability you just choose randomly but
there's also some probability you say
i'm more likely to go to new york than
to des moines
then to yardley pennsylvania or
something like that okay
so that's preferential attachment
there's a still probabilistic you're not
saying exactly what's going to happen
but you let people say
they're more likely to go to a big urban
city okay there's various reasons for
that to be true
um in fact let's say that
yeah that i get this right okay good and
so this turns out
go through the math do the calculations
you get a power law
um your power law for the sizes of
cities
with n of x the number of cities
with population x proportional to x to
the minus alpha
where alpha if i got this correct is 2
minus p over 1 minus p remember p is
this probability that we
choose randomly versus choosing
preferentially
don't don't trust the details here this
is not something that i personally did
this is just i looked up in a paper
um but the point is you get a power law
by this mechanism of preferential
attachment okay
so that's the kind of game again that
you play
in complex systems is you notice
something in the data
you plot the number of cities versus
their population
you notice it kind of looks like a power
law and you say huh can i invent a
theory can i invent a model that
explains that here's a model that
purports to explain it
even if this model fits the data even if
you get exactly the right
power law it doesn't mean the model's
right it just means it's not wrong you
haven't falsified it yet right but
maybe there are other models to get
exactly the same
explanation for the behavior this is why
the the field is
difficult okay um so this but this is
one you know preferential attachment is
one mechanism that leads to power walls
there's there are other mechanisms
so let me mention one called
self-organized
criticality
and one can argue because one does
whether or not this is really the same
mechanism as preferential attachment
just with different words but it
certainly comes from a different point
of view
so this is more you know this sort of
mechanism
preferential attachment is kind of
statistic-y
you know computer sciencey whereas the
self-organized criticality is more
physics-y
so it goes back to this phase transition
idea you know the ising model
has the scale-free behavior but only at
the critical temperature right
and if you're just externally changing
the temperature of something in an oven
or a refrigerator
you'd really have to work to tune things
to be exactly the critical temperature
and yet in nature
we see things that have this power law
critical behavior all the time
why is that so this is an idea of pair
bach
and collaborators i'm sorry i forget the
collaborator's name
sorry about that but he you know he
wrote a paper with other people but then
he kept writing papers on it again and
again became a champion of this idea so
his name is attached to it
and the idea is that you can get
critical behavior that maintains itself
dynamically
so it's self-organized criticality it's
not that
you're changing the temperature knob on
something and externally forcing it to
be at a critical point
if you start away from the critical
point you will get to it in certain
kinds of physical systems okay
that's the idea of self-organized
criticality and the example that he used
over and over again was a sand pile
and ironically it's not all clear
whether this is true for actual sand
piles
but uh again controversy abounds it's a
complex system
so what you imagine is you know pile of
grains of sand
okay and there's some
you know you it's you can't be a square
you mentioned there's a real
pile of sand so that you drop extra sand
grains onto it and if the slope
becomes too large then you get an
avalanche okay
then there's a whole bunch of sand that
falls down so you're dribbling sand onto
a sand pile
and it's building up building up and
then there's a little slippage and
there's an avalanche and it builds up
and there's slippage and there's
avalanche
and the question you ask is how big are
the avalanches
okay so you plot size of avalanche
sorry log size of avalanche
versus the number of them and it's a
power law
am i getting that right yeah i think so
let me make my parentheses consistent
otherwise i think i got it right
um i don't even know what the parallel
is i think it depends on the details of
your model of the sand pile or whatever
but this is but you know there's no
attachment story being told here
uh it's sort of a dynamics of the system
story and it's interesting because
it is an intrinsically out of
equilibrium system you know one of the
things
um i don't have time to go into it but
one of the questions
ask me this and i'll go into the q a um
one of the questions about complex
systems
is how are they do they relate to
entropy right if the only thing that
ever happens in the world is that
entropy increases
then why in the world you get complex
systems like entropy just makes things
more disorderly right
but this is an example of something
which needs to be out of equilibrium
like equilibrium would be the sand is
just all everywhere on the floor
right it's equally distributed here's
something as an external influence
you're dropping sand
into more or less the same location or
maybe even drop it right on the top
but there's some randomness in where it
falls okay
and then that leads dynamically to this
sort of critical behavior
um complex behavior if you want it's not
the most complex thing in the world but
is this
this parallel like behavior so it's an
example like a little hint
of how the fact that you're not a closed
system
means that rather than you know in a
closed system if you just have a box of
gas and you started you know all the
gases in a quarter or there's two
different kinds of gas and they're all
separate from each other
it will naturally mix and go to a high
entropy state to an equilibrium state
and it will stay there
that's the universal behavior this is
not a closed system we keep dropping
things onto it
and so the claim is that there's a
different place it goes
it goes somewhere it goes to this
critical behavior the number of
avalanches
um but it doesn't go to the equilibrium
configuration it goes to this critical
point
and it stays there naturally and i think
that it's safe to say that
it is not fully understood the
conditions under which this happens or
why it happens or the more robust theory
of this
there's certainly a lot of papers
written and maybe i'm even wrong about
that maybe it is completely understood
by somebody else
but i'm just mentioning it as an example
of a way to get
critical-like behavior and i think it's
interesting that it
it intrinsically involves this external
influence
but not a tuned external influence not
an external influence that is trying to
make things like look like a power law
it's kind of a random external influence
that puts it into this power law kind of
state
okay um good
now i would lose my license as a
as a good scientist if i left you with
the impression
that power laws were everything and i
think that you know pair bach
uh who passed away i believe um he
sort of got a reputation for claiming
the power laws were everything and this
is why there was some pushback just
rhetorically like scientists are human
beings too and they have their favorite
ideas and they
push them sometimes but power laws are
not everything and
so there is in particular
other ways to get approximately
scale-free behavior in very similar bias
very similar mechanisms
to what we've looked at here okay so
consider
here's an alternative to power laws
and the alternative is it starts you
know we gave the preferential attachment
model where you have sizes of cities and
there's some probability that you'll
move preferentially to a big city
but what about that's sort of an
additive thing you keep adding more
people so what about multiplicative
models
i'm not sure what the technical term
here is but uh
i'm calling it a multiplicative model so
imagine that
let's say for for example
for size of an organism
so we imagine here is that at each time
step
the size of an organism changes
and it changes in the following way that
the size goes to
some number times what the size was
where this number is a random number
chosen from distribution
random variable and we imagine the
random variable
is maybe like it has a gaussian
distribution or something like that
um or some other kind there's
distributions that you could
have um but the point is that it is you
know
centered near one maybe i guess the
thing could explain it doesn't need to
be centered near one
but the point is it is independent of s
so you multiply the size of an organism
so maybe it grows a little bit maybe it
shrinks a little bit okay
it's a random number so it could
potentially do either one and it does
that over and over again
but the point is that it expands by a
constant factor
not by a constant additive amount so
it's not like you pick a number of
kilograms that could be positive or
negative and you add it to the size
you take what the size already was and
you expand it proportionally or decrease
it proportionally okay that's the trick
of this multiplicative model
and then what you get so you get a
number distribute number density
distribution
as a function of size and you might have
guessed it'll be power law or something
like that because this is
kind of similar to the preferential
attachment idea but it's not
it is a log normal distribution
and that's kind of an intimidating name
so this is um something called the
multiplicative central limit theorem
central limit theorem okay so the
central limit theorem says then we kept
adding random numbers together and we
got a gaussian distribution
so when you multiply remember i already
told you that when you take the
logarithm of the product of two numbers
you get the sum of the logarithms of the
two numbers
so logs and exponentials are related by
changing multiplying into adding and
vice versa
so if instead of adding you're
multiplying
that's kind of like adding the
logarithms right multiplying two numbers
is adding logarithms and then
exponentiating the answer
so what the log normal distribution is
is let's write it down and i'll try to
explain it n of s
is proportional to 1 over s that's an
extra factor that you get in there
times it looks like a normal
distribution remember the normal
distribution was e to the minus
x minus x naught squared over the
standard deviation
so this is going to be e to the minus
log of x
minus let's say l naught squared over
2 sigma squared so it's a normal
distribution
for the logarithm of x not a normal
distribution for x that turns out to
make a huge difference okay if you plot
this
and this is not a log log plot so here's
n of s
versus s it's kind of going to look like
this
so it kind of looks like a bell curve
gaussian thing
near the peak there is a peak right
there is a center here something where
you can actually calculate the mean
it's not right at the peak but it's
close but then there's also this
long tail right that is kind of power
law like so a power law
like you know x to the minus 1 or s to
the minus 1 might look like this
right oops
this is the power law
and law
where this is the log normal
and for large values they look very very
similar okay they are different things
different origins slightly different
shapes but at large values of s
asymptotically they begin to
resemble each other at least a little
bit okay so watch this i'm going to try
to do this i'm going to try to pull in
i made a plot for you look at how much i
care about you folks
um no let's see
no yeah photo library
good check it out look at that
okay so i made a little plot in
mathematica where i plotted on a log log
plot this is log
versus log n okay
so you see that on this plot on a log
log plot the power law in blue is a
perfectly straight line
the log normal in red looks pretty
straight in fact if you sort of had uh
cut it off so if i just stop the plot
there
then just between here to here it looks
very very very similar
so if what you're doing if the game you
were playing was
you start with data and your data points
let's make them bigger than that okay
let's make some big old data points
there's a data point there's a data
point there's a data point there's a
data point because real world data
points
have scatter in them right
so you tell me where those green lines
are best fit by the red line or the blue
line okay so
if you're careful um one of the things
that you need to worry about
in this game is okay you have structure
on many different scales but is it
really a power law or is it a log normal
and the reason why that makes a huge
difference it's not just
a matter of best fitting the data okay i
mean that's good fitting the data well
is good
but you recall from everything we've
just said the underlying
models that give rise to this behavior
are completely different
in the two cases so if you want to make
an argument
why your distribution looks a certain
way it matters to you enormously
whether or not the data are best fit by
a log normal or a power law
okay furthermore look out here
way out here they begin to deviate at
very very large
values of the independent variable so
again if what you care about are the
tails the really really unlikely black
swan events
the difference between having a log
normal and a power law matters a lot
so this is why you know the actual real
world uh applications
of these sort of scale-free behavior or
at least
approximately this there is a scale here
unlike the real power laws
this absolutely scale here there is a
central value and a
standard deviation um but
they look very similar empirically and
so doing this in the real world is hard
that's why you know scientists are paid
the big bucks that's okay
all right i wanted to um end up
just by sort of i told you some of the
basic underlying ideas
behind these complex behavior scale-free
behavior power laws
normals and all that stuff let me just
give a little application
to biology because this is kind of
cool individual organisms so we have the
idea that this field is called
allometric scaling
the the question is how do things
change as organisms get bigger or
smaller in a very general sense
so bigger might mean you know taller or
more massive
and the things you might measure are its
metabolic rate
its lifespan its heart rate its fastest
speed of running whatever it wants to be
various different things that you can
measure as a function of its size
the field of alimetric scaling is how do
features of an organism change as a
function of its size
and this goes back you know how far back
this goes i think
galileo was one of the first people to
talk about this there is a basic
feature that you don't need to involve
complex systems or anything like that
to understand which is just that space
is three-dimensional
okay and what that means is that
different features of an organism
depend differently on its size before
you get to actually what their
dependence is
so there's something that is called the
square cube law
and roughly speaking this is just the
statement that becomes
important in different contexts but the
statement is that in three dimensions
okay if i have something of linear size
l
the area of its boundary whatever it is
in
in two dimensions in three spatial
dimensions so this is a sphere okay
the area is proportional to l
squared the volume
is proportional to l cubed that's why
it's called the square cubed law because
some things
depend on the area some things depend on
the volume and
those things change differently as the
linear size
gets bigger so uh the famous
thing that you might have heard of is
jbs haldane
wrote a famous piece called on being the
right size
right where he points out that for
organisms this makes a big difference
what this means is that you know there
are various things like i said
um what depends on area things like um
cooling if you imagine that you're an
organism
you have a metabolism you're generating
heat inside you need to expel the heat
right and you expel the heat roughly
speaking through your skin
right your epidermis or whatever
different organisms will do different
things but that's a common thing to do
well the amount of heat you generate is
proportional to your volume
but the amount of heat you can expel is
proportional to the area of your skin
so as organisms gets bigger it becomes
harder and harder for them to cool off
right this is a basic fact another one
is
leg strength
if you think about you know the the
volume contained in your leg goes as the
length cube the size
cubed but what matters is sort of the
cross sectional area of your leg that
will that will tell you how strong
your leg actually is so the strength of
your legs
goes as l squared but the mass that
you're holding up goes as l
cubed what that means is for small
things
so you know spiders right for example
spiders have skinny little legs big
bodies and one two
three spiders not insects right eight
legs
well are enough to hold up the spider
tiny little legs also true for insects
uh tiny little legs can hold up a
relatively large body
whereas for elephants
the amount you need to hold up is
scaling as l
cubed if l is the linear size and
therefore
they need these big squat fat legs
and they only have four of them i mean
how is it even possible to get along
which is why by the way king kong cannot
exist
sorry
i already told you in earlier video that
ant-man can't exist because
you can't make atoms smaller uh king
kong can't exist also
because if you just scale up the size of
a gorilla it would have to change its
shape
in order just to walk around in order
not to collapse under its own weight
okay i'm not even going to draw okay
here's an elephant there we go
um this explains so the point of this
reason why this is interesting
is because you might think
if you were so purely a biologist that
you know anything about physics at all
and there aren't any biologists actually
like that but let's imagine a straw
biologist
you might imagine that things like the
shape of different animals was set by
evolution and dna right like there's
some dna sequence
and in principle i could have any shape
i want and you just imagine you know
which ones survive right
this is saying that you can understand
features
of living organisms without talking
about evolution
there are features of living organisms
that are simply true in response to the
laws of physics through the basic way
that things scale
with size okay maybe there are more
things
like that as an interesting current area
of research
and this line of reasoning goes all the
way like if you get big enough
everything becomes a sphere there's a
reason why planets
stars are spheres black holes are
roughly spherical
right because the gravitational pull is
more important than anything else
at some point if you had a much more
massive if you
let's say you have a neutron star okay
it's much smaller than earth but much
more massive
uh the size of ripples on the surface of
a neutron star are proportionally much
much smaller than the size of mountain
ranges
on earth things become more and more
spherical as they become more massive
for exactly this kind of reason one of
the reasons why pluto
sort of only ambiguously a planet is
because it's not clear that it's big
enough that it needs to be a sphere
hydrostatic equilibrium is the technical
term here but one of the
points of definition of what a planet
was according to the international
astronomical union
is that it needs to be spherical it
needs to be in hydrostatic equilibrium
okay that was a that was a digression
but this basic idea of scaling according
to different powers depending on what
property you're looking at was
recognized in biology for a long time
these days it's become a lot more
sophisticated
so now there are measures of metabolism
for example
and what turns out to be the case is
that if you study the metabolic rate
of various different kinds of animals
but you know something in the same
um classification so just like when we
were plotting the
mass of the elephant it was important we
distinguish between you know african
elements and asia
african elephants and asian elephants
because they would have different
distributions likewise you should be
comparing mammals to mammals here
or insects to insects but otherwise you
can
compare many different things it turns
out this scales as the mass
to the one quarter power so the 0.25
power to a very good like this is an
empirical fact
um in fact this is called kleiber's law
i believe
and it's been known for a long time
1930s
something like that um
i mean that's interesting for a couple
reasons it's a power law right
rate proportional to mass to some power
um
it is a weird power law like the
one-fourth power why is it that like
you know minus one plus one you know
these are things we understand like why
one-fourth i mean
empirically if you just get it from data
you don't know it's exactly
one-fourth you fit the best thing you've
noticed that it's you know 0.24
0.26 something close to a quarter and
you wonder is there something going on
that can explain that
and then you notice you know also you
can say things like heart rate
closely related to metabolic rate but
not exactly the same
proportional to mass to the minus
one quarter so metabolic rate is the
total amount of energy that you use
remember the cooling is something that
uh you need to
scale as your as your body's area uh
so you can't have the metabolic rate the
amount of energy being used up in your
body
simply be proportional to your volume
and therefore to your mass otherwise
you'd overheat
for large animals so the metabolic rate
is the total metabolic rate the total
rate at which energy is consumed inside
your body
is higher for large animals but not that
much higher otherwise they would
overheat and die
the heart rate actually is lower for
large animals the heart rate in an
elephant or a blue whale is much smaller
than the heart rate
for tiny little animals for a shrew or
something like that okay
and let's see if i remember this
i think that i even got another plot for
you
photo library yes here we go
check it out so here is the um
metabolic rate of different animals as a
function of their body mass
um and so you can see all the way down
from
small birds and mice much less than one
kilogram
all the way up to elephants and bulls
and horse it's a pretty good fit
this is a log log plot right you can
tell 0.01
0.11 10 100 0.11
100. so log log plot straight line and
the slope turns out to be a quarter
okay um data you know don't don't
tell anyone i never showed you data here
why
why is it not only a power law but look
it's the same power
just with a minus sign clearly this is
not an accident right
can't be an accident well we're not sure
but there's a very good theory
um from jeffrey west jeffrey west was a
guest on the mindscape podcast one of
the very first guests so i
encourage you to go check out that
podcast and he also wrote a book called
scale where he talks exactly about this
in wonderful detail and applies it to
cities um let me tell you something
about cities don't let me forget to tell
you something about cities in a second
but you know cities societies
the internet as well as biological
organisms
so west brown and enquist
in 1997 so very
recently okay this is not ancient news
here
they proposed a model and this is what
we do we see the data
we say why is it like that we propose a
model and we ask if it fits the data and
then we ask if we can test it in other
ways
so they said consider a network
so remember um
preferential attachment model right um
you can think of that in network
terms you can think of every city as a
node and every little line that comes
out of it i mean this is sort of more
inspired by websites i guess but
um yeah let's just let's stick with
websites is it better it's a better
model
uh websites are a network clearly there
are websites and they link to each other
so
the websites themselves are nodes the
edges of the graph and the network are
the links between the websites
and they're ordered you know i can link
to you even if you don't link to me
but anyway it's a network and you can
talk about the degree of that of the
node like how many links are coming in
or coming out
uh so networks are a very common way of
conceptualizing these complex systems
so so consider a network these these
people said
that has the following properties uh
one it's space filling
so this is not something like uh the
website but this is something like where
you have a region of space
three-dimensional space
and you have a network which means you
have some
nodes and they branch off to other nodes
and something like that
and there's some discretization or
whatever maybe there's more
but in some sense you fill up all the
space so maybe like all these nodes take
up a certain volume but
there's no space left unfilled that's an
assumption these are assumptions and
we're going to derive a conclusion from
our assumptions
it is optimal efficiency
so whatever it's doing converting atp
into energy pulling muscles running
around whatever it's doing it's doing it
at the at the most efficient rate that
it can do that so given the fuel it uses
it puts it to use in a very good way
and three it the ends
are constant size
so the the in in between ones like
i'm not sure about this i guess the
in-between ones need not be the same
size
but all the ending ones the terminal
points of the network
where there's no nothing else coming out
only things going in
all of these have the same size okay
that is part of their assumptions
and from these assumptions they derive
they make a theorem
that various properties
are proportional to and then you know
the number of them
you know the number i'm not going to get
the notation right but the properties
are proportional to
the mass which is proportional to the
volume
to n over four where n is a number that
depends on
um whatever property you're looking at
okay so and four
equals the dimensionality of space
plus one so in other words this sorry
this didn't quite make sense because
it's too much detail to actually you
know prove this i'm just stating the
result and explaining why it's
interesting it's interesting because
they propose a set of axioms a set of
postulates that seem superficially
reasonable
for this might be your nervous system
or your circulatory system or your
respiratory system
all of these are networks in your body
okay
so they have you know your brain and it
sort of branches out and all your nerves
and everything
and it fills space so it fills your body
everywhere in your body you have these
nerves
and they end and the brain is bigger
than the individual nerves but all the
nerve endings they assume
are equal sized and they derive
from that the fact that all the
different properties you might want to
measure
of this network will scale as the
size of the organism to some quarter
power i mean mass here is just a you
know a proxy for
density or proxy for volume
because the density of different
organisms is approximately the same
and the reason why is because of a
property of the network
in three spatial dimensions okay
if we were two dimensional organisms
then instead of these quarter
power laws we would get one third power
laws and if space were four dimensional
we get one fifth power laws etc
and that's true it works you know they
they got the right number they explain
the four
that appears in these different
phenomenological empirical power laws
is it right is it is this the
explanation
for why these scaling laws go this way
that i'm not so sure about
but uh i think it's plausible i think
it's very very plausible
and this is the kind of thing that we're
studying this is the kind of thing why
complex systems research is useful
this reminds me of the other plot i
wanted to show you and this is just for
fun but this is another one of jeffrey
west's favorite plots
this is how fast people walk
as a function of how big a city is um
here is the size of a city on the
horizontal axis vertical axis is walking
speed this is another
uh power law you can actually show that
it's a power law people walk faster in
big cities
why it's hard to tell but again you
could imagine coming up with a model
like okay there's more people there
and uh you know there's this is the
problem so i'm not going to tell you the
answer because i don't know what the
answer is
since i'm not going to tell you the
answer you have to think of the answer
yourself and you will soon realize
the problem that you can think of more
than one plausible answer
why do people walk faster in big cities
well maybe big cities
uh attract go-getters that really want
to go
everywhere fast maybe people in big
cities are more likely to work in jobs
that have deadlines that need to rush
around
maybe when people are surrounded by
other people they want to sort of get
out of it very quickly and so they go
faster maybe there's more stimulation
from the news media or from the
environment around them
so you can con you can have all these
different models right and you try to
figure out which one is right and it's
not easy
okay the final thing i will say i'm not
only going to write any equations or
even
sentences i'll just say the brain
by which i mean you can study either the
physical
network wiring of the brain what is
called the connectome you know we have
something like 85 billion
neurons in our brains and they're wired
together in a very specific way
we don't know the wiring diagram for the
brain yet that is one of these big
science projects that is ongoing right
now
but it seems like it is likely to be
some sort of scale-free
complex network even without knowing
that you can actually look at activity
in the brain so
forgetting about the individual wiring
between the neurons
look at you know which side which sites
in the brain light up
while you're awake while you're asleep
things like that and how they uh
fluctuate right and it's basically like
the ising model where you're sort of
looking at domains like are there
bunches of neurons lighting up is there
just one neuron lighting up
how many neurons are lighting up there's
a claim
in the literature that if you look at
the sizes of different regions in the
brain lighting up
it obeys a power law um so it is
critical behavior and there's even an
explanation for that and the explanation
is look
if just the whole brain lit up that
you're not really doing a lot of
thinking
right like that's just like moving in
lockstep it's like the low
temperature-izing model all the spins
are aligned
but if it was just random fluctuations
that wouldn't be good either that
wouldn't be careful thought
um jennifer willett my wife wrote a book
called me myself and why where she
studies you know the brain and the self
and how we come into existence and she
investigated this question and talked to
the experts and one of the experts dante
schiavo
gave her this wonderful quote that says
look you know this brain where
everything is random uh or this brain
where everything is moving in lockstep
this is the brain of an idiot this is
not the brain of someone who's doing
optimally efficient information
processing so the idea that somehow
complex structure is needed to
be conscious to sort of be complicated
enough that we describe people as
conscious creatures and evidence for
that
is that the scale-free behavior that is
uh purportedly seen in the brain
in brain activity goes away when you're
asleep
when you stop being conscious um there's
still low-level
localized fluctuations but they do not
connect
over large distances so somehow the
this manifestation of complexity in
behaviors at
all scales seems to be important in the
brain i'm being very wishy-washy about
exactly what's going on here because we
don't know there are papers in the
literature arguing back and forth
whether activity in the brain is truly
critical or not quite critical
power law log normal other distributions
things like that
so all of which is to say is i hope i've
given you a flavor
for this field of study it's not exactly
my field of study i'm learning more
about it and
it's just fascinating to me uh it's
different in character from the other
stuff we've done in the big
ideas videos but it's important because
you know uh the world is
complicated the world is complex and we
would like to understand
why it has something to do with entropy
and the second law of thermodynamics it
also has something to do with
um collective behavior right
small pieces coming together to do big
things
and the fact that it's pre-paradigmatic
and we don't yet know like the what the
perfect spherical cow
here is is not a bug it's a feature it's
it's part of what makes it exciting like
it's harder in a field like this to get
a killer result that everyone agrees is
really really important
but the chances of getting such a result
are kind of higher
because they're still out there the low
hanging fruit is still to be picked
there's so much we don't understand
about complex systems i think it's
one of the very fun very interesting
very promising places
to look for in science in the decades to
come